well Avengers Secret Wars might be a
little bit away however in the meantime
there are so many extremely important
MCU movies coming out in between now and
Secret Wars now Marvel Studios has a lot
planned a lot of movies a lot of Disney
plus projects plus some special
presentations and we've heard that they
might be considering doing limited
series as well so a lot of content
coming from Marvel Studios and hopefully
most of these projects that are coming
out are pretty decent however today we
are specific specifically going to be
talking about four movies that are going
to pave the way and do all of the
groundwork to set up Avengers Secret
Wars these are going to be the four most
important movies moving forward in the
MCU that are going to directly connect
to what is about to go down in King
Dynasty and Secret Wars while yes some
of the other projects might connect to
it a little bit kind of like the Marvels
the Marvels was a story of its own
however at the end we kind of dove into
the Multiverse a little bit but these
are going to more direct ly set up
things for Secret Wars so I'm super
excited to talk about what is about to
come in the MCU but first big
congratulations to YouTube user Jordan
Jensen 148 for being the winner of last
month's giveaway and we have started the
December giveaway same thing if you want
a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items all you have to do is subscribe to
the channel and leave a comment on our
videos we pick one random comment from a
random video at the end of each month so
the first movie we'll start off with is
one of the most anticipated movies just
in General in the MCU out of both Phase
5 and phase six and that is Spider-Man 4
with Tom Holland returning this doesn't
come as that big of a surprise that
Spider-Man 4 is going to be an extremely
important film for secret wars in the
MCU in general moving forward and no
we're not talking about it being
important because Tom Holland is going
to get the Venom symbiote and become
venom that apparently is not going to be
happening until Avenger secret War so
don't expect that to happen in
Spider-Man 4 however we do know of
course that Spider-Man no way home had
to do with the Multiverse and that's not
something that you just forget you don't
just forget that two other variants of
yourself from two other universes popped
up and helped you take on villains from
their respective universes plus not to
mention an incursion almost happened at
the end of Spider-Man no way home so we
didn't know it at the time but
Spider-Man no way home really did set up
Avengers Secret Wars in a huge way with
the incursion storyline plus not to
mention we have heard that Tom Holland
is going to be the lead in Avengers King
Dynasty however here's the deal we don't
exactly know when Spider-Man 4 is going
to come out we have no doubt that he'll
be the lead in King Dynasty but since we
don't have an official release date the
big question is does Spider-Man 4 come
out before Kang Dynasty or after we've
heard rumors that it's going to come out
after which does make sense they're just
now getting back into the boardroom
talking about what the movie is going to
be about so they're in pre-production in
a very very early stage they're just now
kind of getting the idea of what the
story is going to be be about but if it
comes after Kang Dynasty then that means
the story for Spider-Man 4 is going to
be super focused on the Multiverse and
Kang because you're not really going to
be able to sidestep that story after the
huge movie that is the King Dynasty and
the huge evil villain that came into
play now of course Spider-Man can fight
a Villain Like Kingpin or somebody but
the overall story of the Multiverse will
Loom over the entire movie and
ultimately the end of Spider-Man 4 will
set up Secret Wars in a big way I would
even love it if Spider-Man fought a k
variant in Spider-Man 4 but let us know
what you'd like to see from Spider-Man 4
in the comments down below the next
extremely important movie is shangqi 2
now we already know that the first
shanqi film set up not only the rest of
the Avengers but shangqi to be with the
Avengers in a really big way and
originally the director for Shang Chi
Dustin Daniel keton was supposed to
direct Avengers King Dynasty however we
have recently learned that he is no
longer directing that project however
the report did state that he is still
working with Marvel Studios on other
projects in a pretty big way so he still
could return to direct shangi 2 what's
really big about shangi 2 is the
connection that the tin rings are going
to have to King the Conqueror and shangi
and the legend of the 10 Rings they made
sure to be very vague about how Win w
could have possibly gotten the tin Rings
they did not tell us how he got them
only hinted at stories of how he could
have got them but at this point in time
in the MCU it's pretty clear that the 10
rings are indeed Kang technology
insiders have been stating this for a
very long time now about the tin rings
and about the Bengal that Kamala Khan
had plus now after the Marvels we know
that Kamala Khan has two Bengals and the
Bengals have the power to literally open
up portals to different dimensions that
is 100% Kang technology that is exactly
what he does he is the Conqueror of the
Multiverse he is able to travel
throughout time and throughout space and
not just in our universe but through all
of the universes so we can assume that
the 10 rings are somewhat similar
Ant-Man and the wasp Mania showed us
that Kang uses rings as a part of his
technology basically confirming the 10
rings from shangi are indeed his Tech so
whatever is coming in shanqi 2 is going
to definitely deal with the 10 Rings
since Wong Carol damers and Bruce Banner
were inspecting them and I think when we
dive into shangi 2 we are going to see
that Kang connection with the tin Rings
the question is did Kang directly give
wimu the 10 rings did wiw actually find
them and if so where did he find them
how did they get there let us know your
current thoughts about this in the
comments down below now the next one of
course is one of the most highly
anticipated if not the most highly
anticipated movie in the MCU up until
Secret Wars and that is the Fantastic 4
this movie is quite interesting because
we have heard some very interesting
things about it like for example this
movie will actually take place in an
alternate universe not in the main MCU
616 sacred timeline Universe I've
actually always thought that this was a
really good idea if we are dealing with
the Multiverse and which we are we're in
the multiv ver Saga it would make sense
to show a movie from a different
universe's perspective especially when
in secret Wars all of these universes
are going to start colliding into each
other so the fact that this could take
place in a different Universe I think is
a brilliant idea now as far as how they
could get into our universe well we've
heard a rumor that at the end of the
movie The TVA is going to show up and
save just the Fantastic 4 just the F4
family but if that ends up not being
true then incursions can happen and the
Fantastic 4 could simply collide with
our universe and only Universe survives
maybe our universe maybe theirs but all
of the heroes end up in the same place
so either way there's a way to do this
to where the Fantastic 4 film can take
place in a separate universe and end up
in the same universe as all of these
other Heroes that we're going to get and
speaking of Deadpool 3 of course
Deadpool 3 is that fourth film Deadpool
3 is probably going to be the most
important film between now and Secret
Wars yes even more important than
Avengers King Dynasty if what we've
heard about Deadpool 3 is true then
Deadpool 3 is going to be the actual
start of Secret Wars where we are going
to see a lot of different characters
from a lot of different universes come
together in one place now according to
reports from insiders the TVA of course
since they monitor the entire Multiverse
is going to realize that incursions are
starting to happen universes are falling
apart and they're also going to realize
that there are some Kang the conquer
variants that are out of control who are
trying to control the entire Multiverse
like exactly what we saw in the post
credit scene for Quantum Mania from
there the TVA is going to go to a bunch
of dying universes and save Heroes that
they think will be good in a fight
against King the Conqueror they will
essentially start to recruit a
multiversal Avengers team which will not
only consist of the Avengers but the
X-Men the Fantastic 4 and a bunch of
other Heroes as well and they'll
probably have some villains too I'm
really hoping this is where Dr Doom
comes into play so obviously this one is
a Nob brainer this will be the most
important movie building up to Secret
Wars in the MCU in fact from what we're
told this will happen immediately before
Avengers Secret Wars meaning when
Deadpool 3 ends it'll pick up right away
with Secret Wars so again a lot of
exciting things that are coming in
between now and Avengers Secret Wars yes
it's far away but we have a lot to look
forward to let me know what you're most
looking forward to in the comments down
below and if you have a good theory
about any of these projects be sure to
drop them in the comments please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof